The summer of 1628 was supposed to be the dawn of a new era for Sweden.
The Vasa stood in the harbor like a gilded dream two decks of polished oak,
sixty-four bronze cannons glinting in the sun,
hundreds of intricate carvings twisting along its hull like the fantasies of a king who believed grandeur was its own kind of armor.
King Gustavus Adolphus had demanded perfection and the shipbuilders had delivered.
Or so they thought.
It was a light breeze that did it.
A nothing of a wind, really barely enough to ruffle the sails of a fishing boat.
But the Vasa didn't just lean.
It didn't just correct itself.
It tilted.
And then it tilted some more.
Water sloshed through the open gun ports, rushing in like an invitation it couldn't refuse.
Thirteen hundred yards from shore.
That was all it took.
No storm.
No battle.
No act of God.
Just the slow, inevitable surrender of a ship that had forgotten how to float.
We call this the cannonball threshold.
Most people wait for the earthquake.
They brace for the hurricane, the betrayal, the single blow that will shatter them.
But the truth is we're built for storms.
We're built to weather the worst.
What we're not built for is the quiet accumulation of weight,
those little, unnecessary cannonballs we load onto our decks without ever noticing.
That extra committee meeting you don't care about.
The habit of answering emails at midnight just because you can.
The social media posts you craft with surgical precision,
polishing your life into something that looks impressive from a distance.
Each one, alone, is harmless.
But together?
They shift your center of gravity.
They turn you into a ship with no keel, no real foundation,
just a hull straining under the weight of your own decorations.
At then oh then comes the light breeze.
A slow internet connection.
A broken shoelace.
A single, unremarkable day when nothing terrible happens.
Just enough to tip you over.
So, how do you engineer your own sinking?
It's simpler than you think.
First, you learn the art of the derivative.
Yes.
Never refuse an invitation, no matter how hollow the cause.
Host the dinner party you'll half-ass.
Join the volunteer group that bores you to tears.
The more ornate the obligation, the better.
Let your life become a gallery of commitments you don't actually want.
Each one a little statue on the deck.
Each one making the tilt just a little steeper.
Then, you keep your gun ports wide open.
Every notification, every urgent message, every stray thought let them all in.
A ship needs water to function.
A miserable person needs chaos to thrive.
The more you let in, the more you'll need to carry.
And here's the real trick.
Ignore the keel.
Sleep.
That's for people who still believe in stability.
Quiet reflection.
A luxury you can't afford if you're building a masterpiece of collapse.
A shallow support structure is the key.
The less you invest in the things that actually hold you up, the faster you'll learn what
it's like to heal over.
Finally, maximize your surface tension.
Obsess over the carvings, the way your life looks on paper, on screens and the stories
you tell yourself.
Spend your energy gilding the statues while the hull rots beneath you.
Let the world admire your deck while you forget to check for leaks.
The Vasa sank in perfectly calm water.
It didn't need a storm.
It only needed its own weight.
And that, my friend, is the genius of it.
You don't need a tragedy to drown you.
You just need the discipline to keep adding cannonballs, one by one, until the day comes
when you glance at your life from the shore, and for just a second, it looks magnificent.
And then it doesn't.
The idea of balance is a cruel joke, isn't it?
A well-balanced lifa.
How quaint.
How naive.
Picture it.
A ship, sleek and steady, cutting through calm waters.
The sails are full.
The crew is alert.
The horizon stretches out like a promise.
And then, just then, someone decides to remove the very thing, keeping it upright.
Not a storm.
Not a leak.
No, something far more insidious.
The balance.
Because a ship without balance isn't just unstable.
It's an invitation.
The water doesn't even need to rush in.
It simply waits.
Patient.
Relentless.
And when the tilt becomes too much, when the deck lists just a degree too far, gravity
does the rest, slowly, inevitably.
This is the great unspoken truth about equilibrium.
It's not the absence of chaos.
It's the absence of choice.
Remove the balance.
And what you're left with isn't freedom.
It's surrender.
The kind that doesn't announce itself with thunder or crashing waves, but with a quiet, creeping
certainty.
The kind that seeps into the joints.
The kind that makes you forget you were ever standing at all.
And here's the thing about humans.
We're terrible at balance.
Oh, we pretend we understand it morning routines, evening wind downs, the sacred art of moderation.
But moderation is just another word for compromise.
And compromise is the first step toward the couch.
The first step toward the bamboo that's already been cut.
The temperature that's already been set.
The predators that were never there to begin with.
Consider the pandas, captive-born, soft-bellied, living in their climate-controlled zoos of
convenience.
No struggle.
No hunger.
No need to move.
And what happens?
They don't just stop thriving.
They stop existing in any meaningful way.
Their bodies forget how to bear weight.
Their spirits forget how to reach.
This is the fragility of comfort, not the kind that breaks with a snap, but the kind that dissolves,
molecule by molecule, until one day you look down and realize your own skeleton has gone
soft.
Now, think of the Gothic poets, those night-dwellers, those opium-soaked visionaries who called the
dawn their enemy.
They didn't seek balance.
They sought resistance, a world turned upside down, where the rules of day and night were
rewritten in ink and smoke.
They didn't care about sinking ships.
They wanted to be the storm.
And what about the Breharians, those poor fools who swore they could eat sunlight, who
treated biology like a suggestion rather than a law?
They didn't need balance.
They needed delusion, a way to stare into the void and declare, I am the exception.
But exceptions don't last, not really.
They're just the moments before the water finds its level.
So here's the question.
When the balance is gone, when the ship is listing, when the only thing left is the slow,
inevitable pull of gravity, do you fight it?
Or do you finally understand that the real art isn't in staying upright?
It's annoying exactly when to let go.